un beau 500 $ effectivement quand vont
plus en phase avec les placer un coup
d'oeil du kabuki
également je suis très content est-ce
que ça va vous aider avec l'inflation
tous oui quand-même justement la jolie
et de l'estrie pis ça va faire du bien
mais j'ai l'impression d'entrer racheter
corps humain parce que je dise 500 pire
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui de tout et
rendent chez l'épicier de ces foules
l'électricité des logements tout monde
c'est comme si on me donnait un petit
cadeau que la ferme
alors il y en a qui sont contents
d'autres moins
c'est la mesure dont les gens vont
parler le 500 $ applicable à l'année
2000 21 dans le rapport d'impôt des gens
martin biron michel david jonathan
trudeau une grosse soirée politique deux
grosses nouvelles le budget on parlera
de l'entente libéraux npd
martin 500 dollars
c'est ce qui frappe et là il ya deux
versions déjà qu'ils ont devisé trop
large roulement d'autres qui disent il
fallait viser large
discussion c'est un choix politique sa
frappe l'imaginaire c'est certain et
coûtait 500 dollars au printemps on est
dans une élection partielle il ya eu
élection générale qui s'en vient
l'inflation qui augmente c'est sûr que
les gens qui sont plus à l'aise vont
pouvoir se payer
une bonne soirée au resto en famille ou
un nouveau ipad tandis que les gens
moins nantis vont devons l'utiliser pour
payer l'épicerie mais en fait on
redistribue à tous et lors de la mise à
jour économique à l'automne on avait
donné un montant aux gens plus en plus
grande difficulté ça me rappelle les
bonis à la prospérité de ralph klein en
alberta
quand il avait donné en 2006 400 $ à
tous les électeurs
le premier ça fait quand même a mis un
plafond de 100 mille dollars l'an hot
100 mille les les citoyens n'auront pas
ce chèque là évidemment salle épargne le
premier ministre ainsi que tous les
membres de son cabinet sa voix et lui
éviter des questions les gens qu'allez
vous faire avec votre 500 dollars alors
oui mais ça fonctionne bien
monsieur en alberta savez bien faire
fonctionner cette mesure-là 6,4 millions
le voyait sur le tableau de gens que ça
va toucher ça coûte quand même 3 2
milliards au gouvernement michèle dain
vite qu'en pensez vous bah écoutez on
dit les partis d'opposition déchirer
leur chemise en disant c'est effrayant
on repousse les limites de
l'électoralisme écoutez on est on est à
la veille d'une élection il ya pire pour
un gouvernement qui présente pas un
budget avantageux pour lui mais
maintenant électorale et se reposer une
mauvaise
mesure qui plaît aux gens et qui aide
les gens même si l avantage de
gouvernement est peut être d'intérêt
public et dans ce cas ci on peut
certainement pas parler de clientélisme
ou alors là la clientèle elle est très
large c'est à peu près tous les
québécois bon jusqu'à 100000 dollars
alors je ne vois absolument pas ce qu'il
ya de scandaleux là dedans même si
j'admets que le rap est plus ciblée mais
écoutez l'inflation la normale le pont
inventé il ya une situation réelle à
laquelle les gens doivent faire face et
je pense qu'il est dans l'ordre des
choses que le gouvernement les ied
maintenant j'aurais pu reprocher au
gouvernement de vraiment sacrifié
l'intérêt public à son intérêt partisan
si par exemple il avait négligé des
missions fondamentales de l'état pour
acheter des votes mais là c'est pas ce à
quoi on assiste il ya quand même des
investissements mais massif là une
augmentation de jeu passée 8 % dans le
secteur de l'éducation 6 points 3 % en
santé c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est bien
au dessus de ce qu'on appelle les coûts
de système le qui permettent de
maintenir les services à niveau donc il
ya de l'argent si le plan de refondation
de monsieur de monsieur dubé marchpole
ça soit pas décemment pas ce qui manque
d'argent alors au total ce n'est pas un
mauvais budget on va entendre et après
je vais jouer entendre jonathan sur le
500m et asante le sermon de 6,3 pour ça
c'est énorme et jonathan sur le 500
dollars habile comment vous avez trouvé
ça moi je pense que c'est relativement
habile on pourrait se questionner à
savoir ce qu'est la barrière du sens
mais il aurait pu être un peu moindres
est ce que serait peut être 90000 85000
moi je trouve en avant cette discussion
le par contre l'objet de la difficulté
c'est lorsqu'on doit bien on vient
gratter des gens qui en ont pas besoin
rappelons-nous la première mesure
annoncée en janvier le revenu individuel
c'était maximum 50 mille dollars en
revenus combinés familiale c'était 50
5000 $ à 60 mille dollars revenu combiné
vous passiez à la trappe en ces
problèmes des familles qui ont un revenu
par exemple de 80 90 mille dollars ne
subissent pas les impacts de l'inflation
souvent payent plus cher de loyer plus
charges hypothèques ont des plus grosses
voitures donc ont payé davantage
d'essence et chez les retraités ross
certains vont ils ils font peut-être pas
pitié c'est peut-être plus facile pour
eux de faire face à cette nouvelle
réalité là mais reste que ces gens là
aussi avait besoin d'oxygène ils paient
aussi plus d'impôts sur une base
annuelle donc moi qu'on ait voulu
ratisser plus large tout en s'assurant
que les gens qui font beaucoup plus
d'argent les médecins martin parler des
ministres des dirigeants d'entreprise et
tout ça ces gens là ne souhaiteront pas
un chèque de 500 dollars dans les poches
donc moi je pense que en ce sens là il y
avait un besoin de donner de l'oxygène
le plus de jeunes possible un maximum de
québécois et sa réponse ça répond je
pense à ce besoin très bien on va voir
dans l'autre tableau santé éducation on
ajoute en santé sur 5 1 9 milliard
éducation presque 3 milliards
en pourcentage la santé augmentent de
6,3 donc c'est au dessus de l'inflation
l'éducation 5,4 c'est exactement le
l'inflation enseignement supérieur
13% d'augmentation donc martin en effet
on a une marge de manoeuvre pour
investir dans les missions essentielles
oui il ya de l'argent il y en a pas mal
apport de soirée en fait le ministre
mine provisions pour l'aco ville de plus
de deux milliards et demi
supplémentaires et j ai franchement s'il
y avait promis cette provision
supplémentaire on serait probablement
presque à l'équilibré budgétaire alors
s'il ya eu par exemple de sixième vague
d'ici la fin de l'été ça va donner une
marge de manoeuvre pour des premiers
électorale
agréable mais pour ce qui est de bon ton
classé car le budget de le dernier
budget avant l'élection générale snap
une plateforme électorale et dans le
secteur de la santé on réalise que ce
sera la priorité de la cac il ya de
l'argent pour finir la saison pour finir
le mandat mais le gourou d'argent va
venir après le mans d'hommes monsieur
monsieur en fait monsieur girard donne à
monsieur dubé tous les leviers tout ce
qu'il veut tout l'argent nécessaire pour
être capable de faire cette rénovation
la 54 milliards la santé au québec c'est
énorme jonathan il donne un chèque à
monsieur d'ubs a fait tâche à qui il
donne des formes ce duvet le fort
monsieur dubé sur tourner vers les
québécois ben 10 on va l'améliorer le
système est tant mieux quand on s'assure
oui d'aider les québécois m'a même temps
de répondre aux missions essentielles de
l'état est con on n'a pas tout donné à
la santé on en a mais davantage sans
éducation environnement par contre là où
j'ai peut-être une petite crainte c'est
qu'il faudrait pas s'astreindre à penser
que les problèmes dans le système de
santé en ce moment sont en est
uniquement avec des capacités
financières wii qui sert du besoin
davantage de
somme pour engager formés et cetera mais
j'espère que dans le plan santé parce
que c'est la prochaine étape le diavel
le plan pour mettre fin à l' urgence
sanitaire ensuite le budget dans la
séquence qui va venir c'est le plan
santé au droit ou si vous dire au niveau
de la bureautique ou niveau de la
bureaucratie au niveau de la lourdeur
administrative au niveau de
l'organisation du système de santé
comment on va faire pour refonder ce
site et blanc et non pas uniquement pour
peut toujours d'avoir des rues de lyon
rech exactement exactement il faut que
c'est faux qu'est une chaîne avait de
fouquet mais yahia il ya comme un gros
défi le fauquet pour qu'on en a pour
notre argent autrement dit oui parce que
évidemment c'est un trou sans fond la
sainté on le sait mais quand on se
compare
à d'autres sociétés on n'investit pas
moins en santé on a des plus de médecins
par habitant que dans les zus qu'un de
ne plus d'infirmières c'est vraiment à
la base un problème d'organisation de
culture et c'est ce à quoi monsieur dubé
doit doit s'attaquer et qui est de
l'argent plus tant mieux mais
fondamentalement c'est un problème
d'organisation du travail de culture
dans le réseau alors monsieur monsieur
de gérald donne à monsieur dubé les
moyens mais on peut on peut rater son
coup avec beaucoup d'argent c'est on
engloutit l'argent le depuis 30 ans puis
y'a rien qui s'améliore alors c'est pas
une question d'argent une petite
dernière sur le budget passe t'il le
nouveau test depuis quelques années le
test vers je disais tout à l'heure en
émission spéciale on va le voir sur le
tableau ont réduit de 1000 $ la
subvention pour ceux qui veulent acheter
une voiture électrique est ce qu'on va
pas à contre sens qu'en pensez-vous par
ailleurs est-ce qu'il ya assez de
mesures environnementales
michel david usher avec vous cette fois
ci pour ce qui est de la diminution de
la subvention c'est dommage mais il faut
dire que l'augmentation du prix du
pétrole et certainement aussi un
incitatif que
la perte du mail dollars de subventions
alors à ce niveau là je pense pas que ça
ça diminue beaucoup l'attrait mais
encore là c'est pas juste une question
d'argent il ya une volonté politique
dans le virage vert
c'est très bien de dire on va
électrifier les transports et tout ça
mais quand par exemple on dit belle
malgré tout on bâtit troisième bien il
ya plus qu'une question d'argent encore
une fois c'est une question de volonté
politique et ça il m'a toujours semblé à
monsieur qu'au gouvernement on continue
à se dire l'économie ça la priorité sur
l'environnement est temps que cette
philosophie lavaur et y est je pense pas
qu'on va réussir à atteindre des
objectifs on est déjà loin et on n'est
pas en voie de les atteindre nos pieds
jonathan mois sur la réduction des
subventions pour l'achat des véhicules
électriques je comprends que certains
peuvent être surpris mais bien
honnêtement je n'ai aucun une espèce de
problème avec ça parce que le problème
il à la problématique
elle est différente elle évolue et on
doit s'adapter aussi dans les mesures
qu'on met de l'avant lorsque ces crédits
ont été mis en place c'est parce que
c'était difficile de convaincre les gens
à cause du prix des voitures notamment
de se procurer ces voitures là auront
maintenant il ya des listes d'attentes
de 12 parfois 18 mois pour aller
chercher ces véhicules là tellement que
la demande est forte donc moisson est
capable à la limite de dire ben on pense
réduire la subvention sans nuire à la
demande et pour prendre ces sommes là et
les déplacés ailleurs on pourrait être
plus efficace avoir une action qui va
porter davantage et allons-y on ne
saurait flex au québec le toujours pensé
que dès qu'on met en place un programme
c'est un acquis qu'on peut jamais
revenir en arrière je pense qu'on doit
capables de se donner cette flexibilité
conclusion rappeler de la tuer martin
baba salah la diminution de ces
subventions lettres ou sciences en lien
avec le prix des véhicules qui a
tendance à baisser à la demande qui
augmente mais dans l'ensemble yo yo yo
il ya une pénurie a non seulement de
main d'oeuvre mais aussi de produits et
on voit que le gouvernement est sensible
à cette question là je m'éloigne plus du
plan vert là mais c 'est cécile séduit
certains égards très bien grosse
nouvelle je le disais hier soir je vais
vous faire entendre on a entendu nos
deux invités tout à l'heure mais là
l'opposition dans qui est pas très
contente conservateur le bloc on écoute
comment peut-on croire que cet homme là
monsieur trudeau fait ça pour la
stabilité alors que déclencher une
élection en pleine pandémie le résultat
c'est qu'il fait une entente avec le npd
qui fait en sorte que maintenant c'est
le npd libéral qui mène le gouvernement
il a donné carte blanche au npd avec ce
je pense que c'est tentant cela ne
durera pas je pense que c'est une
extraordinaire naïveté de la part de
monsieur singh et du mpb si le parti
libéral voit une fenêtre pour une
élection qui lui donnerait une majorité
il va jeter le npd sous l'autobus
alors michel david
c'est trudeau donne carte blanche à
monsieur cinq mois je pense que celle
inverse je pensais tout profit pour
monsieur trudeau c'était cette entente
là et ceux qui ne l'empêchent pas comme
dit monsieur
blanchet de déclencher quand même une
élection si jamais la fenêtre s'ouvre
pour les libéraux mais je vois pas
honnêtement je vois mal quel est
l'avantagé du npd là dedans parce que
tous les avantages dont dessus boulerice
vous a parlé tantôt ils auraient pu les
obtenir à la pièce budget après budget
et peut-être même plus alors de donner
comme ça
un chèque en blanc ou littéralement aux
libéraux je vois pas et je pense que ça
risque aussi de
déconcerter passablement de militants du
npd qui vont gérer coutelas
quelle va être la différence dans
l'esprit du lecteur ventes entre nous et
les libéraux et à la prochaine élection
patrice si le gouvernement aux livres et
l'assurance médicaments l'assurance
dentaire c'est pas parce que le npd va
avoir contribué qui vont en tirer profit
les gens vont dire qui a instauré ça
c'est le parti libéral non honnêtement
mais cela doit se frotter les mains mais
peut-être monsieur singh se dit je la
gagnerai pas la prochaine puis je veux
programme dedans pour les enfants
canadiens peut-être qu'il est ailleurs
en tout cas je n'attends qu'en pensez
vous ben pour citizen [ __ ] moi je vous
dirais ils sont cassés comme des clous
ils y ont pas les moyens de repartir en
élection au cours au cours des prochains
mois donc qui s'achète il s'achète
quelques mois donc je pense qu'il y
avait il y avait à gagner le pour eux et
quand je pense à ce que ça représente
pour le parti libéral du canada j'ai
l'impression aussi que au delà de la
capacité à gouverner dans les prochaines
années justin trudeau vient de s'acheter
une paix relative au sein du caucus qui
pourrait lui permettre à terme de faire
une transition en douce en moi je suis
de ceux qui ne croient pas que justin
trudeau vice olinga des parents lors de
la prochaine élection et quelqu'un m'a
déjà dit il ya quelques quelques mots de
sa faux pas lui pousser trop dans le dos
il va finir par comprendre qu'il est
peut-être mieux de laisser la place à
quelqu'un d'autre on peut penser par
exemple à madame fuir end mais six ans
qui est déjà qui manigancent dans son
dos à la limite il pourrait se dire si
vous me provoquer savez vous quoi je
vais rester or le comme il repose
d'urgence j'ai l'impression que
tranquillement pas vite monsieur trudeau
pourraient aplanir certains irritants au
cours des prochains mois voire une deux
années et ensuite peut-être orchestré
une transition en douceur pour donner
l'image d'un certain renouveau avec une
nouvelle personne qui le remplacerait au
poste de premier ministre et de chef du
parti libéral il y en a qui a fait ça
exactement ce que vous décrivez c'est
monsieur chrétien lui avait dit à sa
femme qui partait après deux mandats et
monsieur barbu le pousser puis a décidé
de rester parce que c'est ça qui est
arrivé on le sait pas mais c'est ce qui
dit martin qu'en pensez vous de ceux de
sète de cette entente aussi je pense que
c'est tout à fait al'avantage de
monsieur ludo pour deux raisons d'abord
lors de la dernière élection monsieur
trudeau s'est fait dire par les
électeurs de respecter les élections à
date fixe même dans un contexte de
gouvernement minoritaire
alors en faisant cette entente là il y
envoie un signal qui veulent faire donc
il gagne du temps et la deuxième raison
c'est qu'il ya quand même momentum qui
est en train de se créer dans le cycle
avec la course à la direction parti
conservateur est ce que conservateur un
certain vent dans le dos on sent qu'il
ya un peu plus d'ambiance que dans les
dernières années alors il se préserve de
cette façon là mais je pense que c'est
tout si l avantage du npd si le npd
doit sentir que ça va vraiment pas bien
que ceux ci se retrouvent en élections
il pourrait
il pourrait plus c'est très bien et oui
le npd autre monsieur seuil le npd c'est
autre chose mais d'abord ses députés
l'ont appuyé mais même s'il pourra dire
si un programme dentaire
j'ai contribué c'est quand même c'est
réel pour les gens est-ce que c'est tout
le temps qu'on a c'est à peu près tout
merci à vous trois très sympathique
merci très gentil au revoir au revoir au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit